how's it goin breasts flying Piper sense
it's another slender shoot shoot it's a
slight into mod for slender pretty much
I feel like it's getting what it's
getting a little okay it's getting a
little out of hand with all these
slender things but this one I should
shut up I'm trying to talk hey all right
based upon the ring okay this one
actually looks interesting enough to try
the [ __ ] out in even though sigh I'm
sorry I offended you I love this game's
best game ever don't kill me okay I love
what the ambience starts already that
kind of creeps me out ah let's follow
the railroad ah [ __ ] me that's not where
Nelson really does don't kill me Thunder
I don't know how I got here but this is
a [ __ ] nightmare
I can't even zoom in like the cameras
it's pretty good because I that feature
was kind of dumb if you ask me okay I
see a node over there how the hell do I
get there oh come on
oh okay okay okay don't don't no no no
don't worry about it - to - to - to the
war O'Bannon brothers don't be scared
don't be scared I'm with you don't be
scared
no [ __ ] you I'm going this way
ah come on [ __ ] this
well let it go stop oh [ __ ] we're fine
let's hide behind this tree where is he
I think we chased em okay the thing is
how the hell would I know where to go
oh dude what's going on over here huh
what the [ __ ] shut up shut up all right
Oh tree say me okay bathroom okay we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
yeah yeah deep breath deep breath deep
breath oh that's uh yeah it's again here
that is yeah that's good that's good
suck it don't kill they okay we're fine
so fine hey baby you're shall find you
shall find your bloomer okay cool cool
oh [ __ ] we have a pretty [ __ ] dark way
you know that those things go hell no
hell no I can't run deep breath deep
breath deep breath deep breath [ __ ]
run ah okay let's go over here just just
just talk yes you are so slow the ground
was [ __ ] shaking
ah [ __ ] he's onto me i [ __ ] wanna rape
me
how the hell did he go now
stop turn around period what I'm sorry I
want to know if he's behind me or not
all right what do we got you really need
to work on your exercises but squeezes
what is this I know why was this game
rec she reminds me of path better ones
play that game it's pretty [ __ ]
creepy too
hey Trey he can't chase me here Kenny
what was wrong
that was wrong that was so wrong but
that's okay
don't even think about it okay okay I
see light over here don't so you just
follow the light and you get to a
station maybe we can get all the note
spits maybe we can do it
this map is a lot bigger than the other
one is behind me I got it I gotta get
moving
what it's the bunker again come on dude
I don't need you right now
bunker swing swing swing swing please
Finn Finn Finn Finn Finn Finn Finn Finn
Finn baby got it naylet okay oh they're
so [ __ ] man many of them I guess I
got the right one yeah I guess I got the
right one a baby or the right kind of
wrong this is a lot [ __ ] creepier
than the original I'm not gonna lie go
faster go faster go faster go faster
no no no no no no okay shut up I say
light over here why did you go oh it's
really [ __ ] growing this sound -
isn't that lovely
okay it's okay it's okay okay we're fine
just get on the notes and everything
will be fine it's all the notes I see
light of it oh he's there
what is this a house it can't be a note
in here or can it yes can
oh hey Jake may I get fitted behind you
no no [ __ ] over global Chelle on the
ground shell on the ground shut up
oh you're so slow you're so slow oh
you're so slow okay I don't even know
how many I got shut up
ah a tree you look so bright could there
be something on you okay let's go over
here then
I don't even know anymore why the hell
it ago oh dude
ah boy girl
oh shut up I know he follows me what is
that
don't give me obvious thing up okay bro
we got six out of eight that's pretty
impressive if you ask me let's just keep
going in circles six out of eight why
don't you get learn to skate
come on look you shut up
I'm sorry shut up shut up shut up down
one I hate that I get a get up get on a
mom wait I've been in here for so long
now I don't even know a train hyah
okay we just need two more does mod so
weird how he just disappears this is
another place I do think it is
I quite dude no it's not Oh dabba dabba
doo doo dabba dabba doo that took me
forever that was a good run but I'm not
gonna play that again
I was great one good job nice Maya it's
freakiest [ __ ] as always I love you
download drooper in the sniffer and out
like crazy if you enjoyed subscribe
I fast what do you call it then capable
movement
nice doing what you doing give us it up
a lot
oh nice hey riddle I didn't you know you
were head Jeremy
oh man Rhonda God
hey hey okay let's go